What is this brief mortal life
if not the pursuit of legacy
Someone stole vhagar
there is a debt
we play an ugly game to be paid
this is the highest of treasons
if you want to be a strong Queen
your subjects must fear you
I promise you in time you
and I together will prevail
fire is such strange power everything that
House Targaryen possesses is owed to it
now they see you as you are
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie this will be my Full House of the
Dragon episode 7 trailer video there's a whole
bunch of Easter eggs here so we'll break it all
down if you're brand new to the channel I'm doing
videos for all the episodes be sure to subscribe
to get them careful from spoilers from the last
episode episode 6 if you haven't seen it yet
but just starting at the beginning of the trailer
footage it seems like the main part of the episode
covers laena velaryon's funeral on driftmark high
tide like they're having the funeral ceremony here
bearing her according to the customs of house
velaryon that's why they're giving her a sea
burial like they push the body in the casket
into the sea technically she died by cremation
like she asked vegar to give her a sad ricarus and
burn her but it didn't completely incinerate her
body like there is a body inside that casket it
seems like for the most part the people who are
here are the small Council in the Targaryen and
the velaryon families I don't know if there's
going to be a bunch of other great houses there
but it seems like it's just them because you see
most of them inside the high tide throne room like
that big main room that we got a teaser for in the
previous episode we'll just spend more time in
there the unfortunate easter egg they're paying
off with this is is that Laena velaryon literally
told Daemon in the previous episode she wanted to
go back to driftmark and she's getting her wish
just not quite what she expected she also told him
that she wanted to die a dragon Rider's death but
she didn't know she didn't realize that her death
was going to be coming so swiftly the voiceover is
from her father Corlys Velaryon talking about the
pursuit of legacy and that's just the whole idea
of the battle lines being drawn in them really
going at each other like who is going to win the
Iron Throne like how hard are we going to fight
each other for this one of the other things you
notice here in the funeral scene is that they're
using the same young versions of the actors so I
don't know if they're going to age them up later
in the timeline later episodes or during season
two or something like that because between this
and the actual Dance of the Dragons there is a
bit of a time Jump so like some of these younger
actors would be much bigger would have aged way
up also if you look in the behind the scenes for
episode 6 most of the chirons were the younger
versions of the actors are talking about playing
their characters like how excited they are to join
the show it says younger version of aegon younger
version of Jakira so it's like okay maybe they'll
have older verse in later episodes I'm not totally
sure which ring rhaenys is dropping on the table
here but I think that's the idea that they're
slowly drawing battle lines like Which side will
each great house take who will the velaryon side
with the ring could be hers like it could be a
Targaryen ring that she got from her family or it
could be laena velaryon ring they show more scenes
of vegar and obviously a big thing during this
episode seems like somebody coming along to steal
vhagar and it seems like it's going to be aemond
targaryen he writes him in the books you see him
on the beach you see him staring up in the dark
the whole thing they were teasing in episode 6 was
him not being able to get a dragon like him trying
to claim dreamfyre in it going terribly and then
the dragon dream that Helena Targaryen had he'll
have to shut one eye in order to claim a dragon
basically basically saying that he's gonna have
to lose an eye to get a dragon but that he would
get a dragon so it does sound like Aemond winds up
claiming vegar during this episode because Baela
and Rhaena say somebody stole vegar like they're
trying to wake up jacaerys here in his bed so it
sounds like he's successful but there's this huge
brawl that you see happening inside driftmark with
like all the families all the children and you see
in the background like aegon looks really sad
he's kind of downcast alicent gets really pissed
off at rhaenyra and they talk about high treason
it sounds like the children fight like something
happens between the children there's a brawl and
amends up losing his eye during that and that's
why alicent is so pissed off at rhaenyra like she
blames rhaenyra and her children for everything
that happened that's what she probably means
when she says a debt must be paid when you see
alicent on the Targaryen ship coming to driftmark
there's a voiceover telling someone about becoming
a strong leader and the people fearing them
that actually could be voice over to rhaenyra
even though they've already said that the Fire
and Blood book that this is based on was written
by maesters and it's meant to be a slightly
inaccurate account of History like the show
is meant to be the truest version because you're
actually seeing it play out in front of you the
maesters actually refer to rhaenyra as maegor with
teats also in previous episodes I believe it was
Otto Hightower talking about Daemon potentially
being another maegor like that was the big fear
in the early episodes if he were to take the Iron
Throne like we'd have another maegor on our hands
you see rhaenyra wearing the black like we're
talking about the dance of the Dragons the sides
are the greens and the blacks but in the previous
episode renura wasn't wearing black they said they
tried to make her look as close to the young
version of Vernier as possible to kind of ease
the time transition even though it was 10 years
so she was meant to look a little bit like the
way that Millie Alcock looked like their outfits
were very similar their hair was very similar you
also probably noticed when they show some views
of the back of her hair her hairdo looks a little
bit like daenerys's hairdo the special braids
that they had in it they also did that with a
young version of rhaenyra too I think it was
even in episode one when her father was having
the Realms where fealty to her they wanted her to
look very much like Daenerys this is just another
scene of vhagar opening her math getting ready
to breathe fire there's probably just a moment
where vegar almost seems like she's about to roast
him completely sort of like a Twist on his attempt
to try and claim dreamfyre like he almost got
roasted that time almost gets roasted this time
but this time he's successful as rhaenyra talks
about the history of their family the role of
fire engine dragon fire in the success of the
history of their family how they were able to
use dragons to conquer Westeros this is another
one of the scenes in driftmark like you can see
the same monument in the background the same
staircase this is just another scene of vegar
opening her eye in the middle of the night this
is that scene of baela and rhaena coming to wait
jacaerys claiming that someone has stolen vhagar
like I said probably gonna be Aemond just based on
the foreshadowing with Helena Targaryen he'll have
to shut one eye then they actually cut a bunch of
different scenes here with laenor velaryon and
his lover Qarl Correy so it seems like they get
into a sword fight but there's a separate overhead
scene in that hallway where the figures are kind
of small so you can't see perfectly but the white
hairdo that's strangling Qarl Correy here looking
like they're killing them doesn't seem like it's
meant to be laenor velaryon like it looks like
Daemon is actually killing him and if you weren't
sure what was going on in the hallway here like
all the monuments around driftmark are meant to be
from his nine voyages the sea snake's nine voyages
these actual helmeted skulls seem like they
belong to the Yogo snai which is like another
race in essos you could spend all day talking
about all the different Easter eggs from all of
his different nine voyages and all the different
places in the world most of the places that these
are from are places that we haven't visited on
the show yet they might be saving some of this
to pay off and other spin-off and other prequel
series is not totally clear why Daemon would be
killing Qarl Correy but what he might be doing
is clearing the path to actually marry rhaenyra
but she's married to laenor velaryon right now so
we talk about all the crazy stuff that Damon does
to try and get the iron throne and in the previous
episode the whole theme was he wasn't really sure
what he was supposed to be doing with his life
like he was kind of languishing over in pentos
it sounds like he's inspired by the death of his
wife and what she told him to actually continue
his pursuit of the Iron Throne so what he might
be doing is just getting rid of renira's current
husband Laenor velaryon and his lover to clear
a path so that he can marry her legally this
hooded figure in the bay with the white long
hair might just be a version of Daemon like
I said when alicent is talking about this debt
being paid inside high tide you see aegon behind
her seeming really sad about what's happened
it's probably after that fight it probably has
something to do with Aemond actually losing that
eye this seems like a different place where the
children get into a fight and the eye is actually
lost when rhaenyra is talking about this highest
of treasons that probably has something to do with
the beef between them because of Aemond losing his
eye this is just alicent's father Otto Hightower
becoming hand of the King again coming back into
the story because he's been down in Old Town for
the past 10 years since he got fired as hand of
the king but the whole thing during episode 6 as
they actually explained after the episode is that
larys strong was using alicent's circumstances as
an excuse to get rid of his family that's why he
did it like he wanted to get rid of his family and
he was looking for an opportunity to do it and he
just used this when alicent said I wish my father
were here there was a lot of confusion about why
he would do that after episode six like why would
he kill his family but the way they talk about it
they just make it sound like he wanted the title
like he wanted to become a lord of harrenhall
because he's way more powerful now he has way more
money the whole thing with blackmailing alicent
too I'm sure you'll reward me when the time comes
I believe is meant to be when he thinks that aegon
II eventually takes the Iron Throne like he's
backing the greens assuming that they'll win
in trying to put himself in a really favorable
position so he probably probably wants alicent
to put him on her small council like we'll call
them the green council because this other council
of rhaenyra's is called the black council is sort
of like the different sides we'll talk about that
in later episodes too then we get the big scene
of alicent attacking rhaenyra with the valyrian
dagger you notice that she just pulls it right off
of her husband viserys and because his illness has
left him so in feebled he can't stop her from
yanking the dagger off of him and it looks like
she means to attack rhaenyra but I don't think
that she's trying to kill her what probably winds
up happening because you see rhaenyra bleeding
later and saying ah you finally shown them who
you really are basically like trying to out her as
being this terrible person in front of everybody I
think the idea is that she was just trying to
scare her and it's like an accident like she
didn't actually mean to stab her with the Valyrian
dagger and just winds up cutting her a little bit
and it's one of those situations where things just
go a little too far like aemond losing his eye is
probably a situation like that like the children
fight and he probably accidentally loses his eye
and then rhaenyra responds in kind and things
escalate to the dance of the Dragons because
later you get the voice over from alicent's father
saying we're playing a dangerous game are you sure
you have the grit to try and win it like are you
sure you're ready to play this to the logical end
because a lot of people are probably gonna die and
she seems pretty crestfallen so I think that she's
probably upset about what happened the same is
what happened with larys at the end of last week's
episode she was kind of horrified when she found
out what he'd actually done like I didn't tell
you to kill them why would you do that the whole
reason is that he was playing her like he's trying
to blackmail her so what they're trying to show
you is the circumstances that led to the dance
of the Dragon so like neither one of them alicent
or rhaenyra like really wanted to go at each other
you can see how the circumstances around them and
the people around them too are influencing that
decision like over on rhaenyra's side you also
have Daemon being this force of chaos killing
all these people so the whole idea is that both
of these different size the blacks and the greens
wind up doing terrible terrible things but a
lot of it winds up being kind of on accident I
think one of the other big hanging plot threads is
what's going to happen to viserys because there's
other footage of him from the previous trailers
from forward in the timeline so if we think of
him as like the Ned Stark of the Season like the
Sean Bean of the season when is he going to die
right now I'm assuming that he probably winds
up passing away in episode 9 because they can't
really start the actual dance of the dragons like
the actual conflict until he actually passes away
but it could always be before that like we have
episode 8 who knows what happens in that so post
all your predictions in the comments below there's
a bunch of stuff coming up this week a couple
bonus videos and a couple other big episodes
from the other series that I'm covering they also
released a teaser video for The Last of Us series
that's going to premiere next year I'll probably
do episode videos for that as well but obviously
that's totally different from House of the Dragon
Game of Thrones stuff my full episode 7 video
will post next week after they release it everyone
click here for my full episode 6 video and click
here for all my other house of the dragon videos
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!